Das ist das schlechteste, das ich je in meinem Leben gehört habe.
Ja, das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 52 und ja, Chaosradio Express wird moderiert von mir, von Tim Pritlove am Apparat und ich bin nicht alleine, wie es die Regel ist bei Chaosradio Express, sondern ich begrüße Nibbler an meiner Seite. Hallo Nibbler. Denn das Thema heute soll sein Voice over IP Systeme und ja, mit einem Schwerpunkt auf, ja mal gucken, wo der Schwerpunkt so liegt, das wissen wir glaube ich selber noch nicht so ganz genau und du bist da, weil du dich mit so etwas beschäftigst, du gehörst zu den Leuten, die einem eine halbe Stunde, bevor man mit so einem Podcast anfängt, kurz im Jabber irgendwas mitteilen, dass sie gleich rumkommen, weil du sitzt ja schon in der Straßenbahn. Was hat du da für ein Gerät am Start?
Das war ein Communicator.
Ein Nokia-Communicator. Und wie macht man da drauf dann Jabber?
Da ist ein SSH-Client drauf. Und auf so Geräten, wo man SSH-Client hat, hat man so den ganzen Rest, denn man braucht E-Mail, RSC, WeChat und natürlich auch Jabber.
Gut, der geneigte Hörer versteht schon, hier geht es ums Detail. Deswegen habe ich dich auch eingeladen. Das Thema soll sein Voice over IP. Das steht ja eigentlich schon lange auf der Liste. Also auf meiner Liste, aber auch so auf der Liste der Medien. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich schon vor zehn Jahren von irgendwelchen leicht erhitzten Medienvertretern gefragt wurde, wann es denn nun endlich soweit sei, wann das Internet die Telefonie übernimmt, weil damals glaubte ja jeder, dass das Internet sowieso bald alles übernimmt. Wir wissen, es kam alles etwas anders. Und nirgendswo hat es so lange gedauert wie beim Telefon. Weil ich finde, eigentlich kann man auch nicht davon reden, dass das Internet die Telefonie übernommen hat. Oder hat sie schon?
Es kommt drauf an, also in Teilen schon. Das ist die Frage, mit welchen Leuten man sich da austauscht.
Kommt darauf an, wie man fragt, meinst du?
Richtig.
Na ja gut, wenn man so in seiner eigenen, in seinem eigenen Horizontbereich bleibt, ist natürlich immer etwas schwierig. Aber wie verbreitet ist Voice over IP eigentlich wirklich? Ich glaube alle haben immer gedacht, die Revolution findet so beim User statt. Und die Wahrheit ist, es geht alles von hinten nach vorne.
Im Prinzip schon, ja. Also in den Netzen verwenden die Carrier schon seit längerem, um Gespräche zu übergeben, Voice over IP einfach, weil es bequemer ist, weil es günstiger ist und weil man da viel flexibler sein kann. Also wenn man jetzt nicht unbedingt eine verbindungsorientierte Leitung von A nach B braucht, um jetzt ein Gespräch abzuwickeln, sondern das einfach über IP machen kann, was man eh schon zwischen den Netzen spricht.
Man kann Geld sparen.
Man kann Geld sparen, ja.
Ist das die Hauptmotivation?
Ähm, erstaunlicherweise schon, ja. Auch wenn dann die meisten User, die ich so sehe, im Nachhinein dann sehen, das Telefon ist teurer und die Telefonanlage auch, und Maintenance-Aufwand und so weiter ist alles viel höher. Also unterm Strich ist es für den User wahrscheinlich dasselbe, aber das Telefonieerlebnis ist halt ein anderes.
Und wie ist das Telefonieerlebnis dann? Schlecht?
Persönlich gesehen angenehmer, aber es ist halt IP-basiert. Und wenn Internet weg, das war ganz putzig. Ich war bei meiner Krankenkasse und sah da so dieses schicke Cisco-IP-Telefon auf dem Tisch, fragte sowieso, das Befinden sei mit dem Telefon. Ja, naja, es ist eigentlich alles so wie früher, nur wenn der Computer nicht geht, geht der Telefon auch nicht.
Ah, warum? Also das Telefon ist ja nicht an den Computer angeschlossen.
Das nicht, aber beide leben vom selben IP und wenn das IP weg ist, dann...
Ach so, also wenn das Internet nicht geht.
Richtig.
Genau, das ist halt die Idee, dass man das dedizierte Telefonnetz ersetzt durch das universelle Internet, weil man da so schön Daten übertragen kann und irgendwann auch auf die Idee gekommen ist, man könnte ja dann auch gleich Sprache übertragen. Aber da gibt es einige Probleme. Zum Beispiel auch das Problem, das ich hier beim Aufzeichnen von Podcasts habe, in dem Moment, wo irgendwie alles digital wird und sich in Datenpakete verpackt, dann kriegt man immer so eine ganz unangenehme Latenz rein. Dieses knallharte, ich hör dich sofort, wenn du irgendwas sagst, wo man auch wirklich sehr interaktive Gespräche führen kann. Das leidet schon so ein bisschen in dem Moment, wo man telefoniert über das Internet. Das ist meine Erfahrung.
Das leidet deutlich, ja. Also es kommt drauf an, wo der Teilnehmer gerade sitzt, hinter was für einer Anbindung und auf was für Kodex man verwendet. Das wird dadurch nicht von der Latenz her niedriger, dass man die Pakete nochmal einpackt, über IP verschickt und dann wieder auspackt und so weiter. Das ist im Gegensatz zu dem, was man so von ISDN gewöhnt ist, die klassische leitungsgebundene Telefonie. Da steckt noch einiges mehr dazwischen, wo sich dann die Sprachdaten aufhalten und auch die Codex, die eben verwendet werden. Das ist nicht der ISDN-Codec, den man da ausschließlich verwendet, sondern eben auch andere Codex, wo man schon allein vom Codec her mal 25 Millisekunden zusätzlich einplanen muss fürs N-Coden, fürs D-Coden. Und dann kommt natürlich noch dazu, dass so eine Internetverbindung grundsätzlich mal eine Latenz hat, die höher ist als Telefon. Wobei ich das heute Nachmittag bei einem Bekannten hatte, hat er ja mal so Spaß und Cyber über UMTS eine Verbindung hier in Berlin-Mitte aufgebaut, wo das UMTS eine Zeitweg stabil ist. Und das hat funktioniert. Also man hat eine spürbare Latenz gehabt, aber...
Womit hast du jetzt diese Verbindung? Also UMTS, Mobiltelefon, Datenkommunikation, das ist das, was du meinst. Du hast einen Internetzugang über UMTS-Netz gemacht. Und dann hast du dann...
Da einen OpenVPN-Tunnel durchgeworfen, weil natürlich die UMTS-Anbieter das gar nicht gerne sehen, wenn man da SIP drüber spricht und alles Mögliche dagegen tun, dass man das eben nicht tut. Und dann nach Hause getunnet quasi das IP-Telefon ans Notebook angeschlossen, aus dem das sauber IP gefallen ist. Und das einzige Problem, was man da so hat, ist Jitter. Also Jitter spürt man stark. Jitter bedeutet, dass Pakete nicht in der gleichmäßigen Latenz ankommen. Also dass nicht die Pakete immer 70 Millisekunden von A nach B benötigen, sondern diese Zeitdifferenz mal 70, mal 80.
Sondern dass es mal etwas schneller geht und dann wieder etwas länger dauert, bis die Pakete ankommen.
Richtig, genau. Und das hört man deutlicher als Latenz. Also mit Latenz kann der Kopf scheinbar umgehen. So 20 Millisekunden mehr oder weniger spielen da keine Rolle. Aber ein Jitter ist...
Ich würde ja sagen, also 20. Also im Gespräch sind 20 Millisekunden vielleicht noch zu vertragen. Aber wenn man sich selber hört... Dann ist es wirklich furchtbar. Also ich kriege ab 10 Millisekunden echte Probleme. Ja, das ist schlimm. Ja, gut, aber damit sind wir eigentlich schon mitten im Thema. Also die ganze Einführung von Internet, Telefonie ist eine der langsamsten Revolutionen seit Langem. Was wahrscheinlich einfach auch daran liegt, dass das Telefonsystem so gut funktioniert. Also ich meine, das hat sich einfach über eine extrem lange Zeit entwickelt. Und auch wenn man eigentlich mit allen Details zufrieden ist, man muss immer sagen, das ist alles sehr seriöses Ingenieur-Wesen. Genau, das funktioniert einfach. Man nimmt so das Teil ab, man ist irgendwie gewohnt, es macht sofort tut und sowas. Schon das, das ist meine Erfahrung, ist bei Internet-Telefonie überhaupt nicht gewährleistet. Weil man einfach so viele Punkte hat, die heute noch kranken, wo es einfach nicht läuft. Trotz alledem hat es natürlich so seine Vorteile, weil vor allem, das hatten wir ja schon, schön billig. In dem Moment, wo man sowieso Internet-Flatrate hat und übers Internet telefoniert, hat man einfach mal null Extra-Kosten. Und das natürlich bei ISDN und ganzen anderen Sachen, trotz aller Flatrates und so weiter, insbesondere bei Ferngesprächen in der Regel ein echtes Problem.
Ja, sobald das Gegenüber auf jeden Fall ein IP-Telefon hat, macht das deutlich Spaß, weil man dann natürlich nicht nur Sprache übertragen kann, sondern auch Video und was weiß ich was alles. Also die Standards, die man heute verwendet, wie jetzt Zip beispielsweise, sind in der Form offen, als dass man da nicht nur Sprachdaten übertragen kann, sondern das ist ein generisches Signaling-Protokoll. Also da kann ich Video durchwerfen, mein PBX kann mir beteiligen, also meine Telefonanlage kann mir beteiligen, da hat ein Nachrichten für dich in deiner Mailbox. So der Komfort, dem man sich damit basteln kann. Und basteln ist, glaube ich, das richtige Wort momentan noch. Das ist einfach mal ein ganz anderer als bei der klassischen Telefonie. So klassische Telefonie ist Rufnummer wählen, mit dem Gegenüber sprechen, auflegen, fertig.
Gut, ich meine, da gibt es jetzt eine ganze Menge dreibuchstabiger Abkürzungen, die wollen wir auch gleich alle noch weiter erwähnen. Was ich mal ganz praktisch fände, ist, dass man sich jetzt mal vergegenwärtigt, was sich eigentlich durch Voice over IP konkret verändert im Vergleich zum normalen Telefon. Ich habe jetzt mein normales ISDN-Telefon auf dem Tisch. Da steht es hier auch gerade. Du bist jetzt bei dir zu Hause und du hast auch dein ISDN-Telefon. Dann nehme ich das irgendwie ab, dann macht es tut. Das tut, kommt dann in der Regel von der Vermittlungsstelle. Ich gebe deine Rufnummer ein. Deine Rufnummer ist im Telefondatennetz erfragbar. Er weiß, wohin er eine Verbindung schalten soll. Dann bekommen wir eine direkte Audio-Verbindung, die zwar auch schon digital ist. Das hatten wir auch schon mal hier bei Chaosradio Express ausführlich diskutiert, zusammen mit Tobias, über digitale Telefonnetze. Du nimmst irgendwie ab und dann können wir miteinander reden. So kennt es jeder. Angenommen, dieses Telefon wäre jetzt ein IP-Telefon. Das hier ist es nicht, aber hier hast du ein schickes Stehen. Das ist ein Nomm 360, hat viele Tasten, muss ich sagen. Du auf der anderen Seite auch. Jetzt nehme ich den Hörer ab. An dem Ding steckt ja dann nicht ein ISDN-Kabel, sondern...
Ethernet.
Ein Ethernet-Kabel. Bei einem Kabel kann man sich alles mit WLAN vorstellen, aber das spielt jetzt hier auch keine Rolle. Das heißt, an diesem Telefon ist dann Internet dran. Jetzt nehme ich den Hörer ab.
Na, im Prinzip tut das genauso. Nur das Tuten kommt eben vom Telefon und nicht vom Netz, weil das halt da generiert wird.
Weil es in dem Sinne gar kein Netz mehr gibt. Es gibt nur das Internet und das tutet nicht.
Genau.
Zumindest nicht so ohne Weiteres. Vielleicht tutet es auch, aber man weiß nicht wo. Okay, das heißt, ich nehme den Hörer ab und es tutet. Ich habe schon das Gefühl, alles wäre so wie früher, aber es ist schon mal nicht so, weil es einfach das Telefon selber was sagt. Ja, ich tue jetzt mal so, als gäbe es.
Bei dem User beruhigen.
Genau, erst mal beruhigen. Gut, jetzt wähle ich deine Telefonnummer.
Dann können ganz viele bunte Dinge passieren.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9. Was macht das Telefon?
Na, das Telefon hat dann mehrere Möglichkeiten. Entweder es sucht sich, das bietet dieses Num sogar lustigerweise, wenn man keinen Account einrichtet, einem an. Das ist ein Protokoll, das auf DNS aufsetzt, das Telefonnummern auf IPs umwandelt.
Wofür steht das?
Enum steht für Telefon-Number-Mapping.
Telefon-Number-Mapping.
Wenn man sich Tim dumm anhört, hat man das Enum genannt.
Man will eine Zuordnung haben von einer Telefonnummer auf was?
Im Prinzip auf eine IP.
Eine IP, also eine Internet-Protokolladresse, eine IP-Adresse, damit ich im Internet einen anderen Ort anrufe.
Genau, beispielsweise das Telefon auf der anderen Seite.
Das Telefon auf der anderen Seite. Ok, so, und was, und Enum basiert auf DNS. Also auf dem Domain-Name-System, sprich so wie ich, wenn ich irgendwie chaosradio.ccc.de in meinen Webbrowser eingebe und er diesen Namen umwandelt in eine IP-Adresse, so kann ich jetzt auch eine Telefonnummer umwandeln.
Genau, wie bei Domains hat man auch bei Telefonnummern ja eine hierarchische Struktur. Du hast irgendwie vorne das www, was irgendwie so das Untergeordnete ist. Dann kommt ccc, also das Identität, und.de. Das ist quasi der Top-Level, sprich Deutschland. Sprich, es geht von links nach rechts raufwärts in der Hierarchie bei Telefonnummern. Das ist andersrum. Da geht es von, ne, das ist genau so, von links nach rechts, also plus 4,9. Also ist andersrum, von links nach rechts.
Also im Prinzip muss man eine Web-Adresse von rechts nach links lesen, eine Telefonnummer liest man von links nach rechts. Und von links nach rechts wird es immer spezifischer, während eine Web-Adresse von rechts nach links immer spezifischer wird.
Dann haben wir deine Landesvorwahl, unter der Landesvorwahl die Ortsvorwahl, dann deine Rufnummer, unter der Rufnummer noch mal irgendwie so dein Durchbeil-Blog, was eben das www. oder chaosradio.de entsprechend bei einer Domäne.
Genau, also eigentlich hätte ich jetzt hier in Berlin, habe ich so Telefonnummer, Punkt 3 0 Punkt 4 9, das wäre so das Äquivalent.
Genau, also die Diener an jeder Ziffer auf und beispielsweise 0 3 0 2 2 7 0 wäre dann andersrum gelesen, weil die Nässe andersrum läuft die 7 Punkt 2 Punkt 2 Punkt 0 Punkt 3.
Jetzt nicht verzetteln.
Ja, Punkt 9 Punkt 4.
Das heißt, jede einzelne Stelle wird quasi so gesehen, als wäre immer noch ein Punkt dazwischen. Es geht von oben nach unten. Und wo kriege ich überhaupt so eine Rufnummer her? Also ich meine, was führt dazu, dass ich über das Internet, über DNS so eine Rufnummer in der IP-Adresse auflösen kann?
An dieser Domain hängt hinten das Punkt E164 Punkt APA dran. Die Domain E164 Punkt APA wird von der RIPE verweitert, die auch die IP-Adressen in Europa und Umland verweitert. Und die ganzen anderen Numbering-Resourcen wie AS-Nummern. Und die geben das weiter an die jeweiligen Registries, die im Land zuständig sind. Das ist für Deutschland die DENIG, wo auch die Punkt E-Domains herkommen. Und man kann im Prinzip zu jedem DENIG-Mitglied gehen und sagen, registriere mir bitte bei der DENIG diese Telefonnummer. Die haben natürlich dann die Verantwortung, zu überprüfen, ob die Telefonnummer auch dem Teilnehmer gehört. Und wenn das korrekt ist, dann kriegt man diese Telefonnummer im E-Nummer-Format delegiert.
Was heißt, die muss mir schon gehören vorher?
Die muss dir gehören, du hast ein Telefon, das klingelt, wenn man diese Rufnummer anruft, beispielsweise ein Telefonanschluss.
Aber denke ich mir die selber aus, die Rufnummer, oder was?
Nee, die Nummer ist deine Rufnummer, die du so hast. Da kannst du deine Mobilnummer nehmen, da kannst du deine Festnetznummer nehmen.
Das heißt, es geht um die Rufnummer, die ich sowieso schon habe?
Genau. E-Nummer ist an der Stelle einfach eine Transition-Technologie, wo du eben eine Telefonnummer, die du bereits hast, eine Eigenschaft zuweisen kannst, dass sie via IP erreichbar ist.
Aber wie belege ich denn, dass ich diese Rufnummer habe? Also wenn ich jetzt zu meinem Webseiten-Provider gehe und sage, guten Tag, ich hätte jetzt gerne diese Telefonnummer auf meinem Computernetzwerk umgeschaltet?
In der Praxis ist das relativ straightforward. Sie rufen einfach die Nummer an und geben dir einen Token, sagen die irgendwie in der Ziffernation an.
Okay, aber was ist, wenn ich die Rufnummer zwei Tage später kündige? Dann kriegen die das ja nicht mit.
Das ist eben eine der Sachen, die man da noch lösen sollte.
Oh, ja, weil, ich meine, da gibt es ja keine direkte Verbindung. Ich meine, das ist so zu überprüfen, was ich gerade habe. Ich meine, das beweist ja auch nicht, dass das meine Rufnummer ist. Ich weiß ja nur, dass ich da jetzt gerade in der Lage bin, anzurufen. Das heißt, ich kann auch jemandem das Handy klauen. Okay, das sind ja rosige Zeiten, die dann vor uns stehen. Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, das wäre jetzt alles total legal. Und ich bin ja ein aufrechter Bürger, du ja auch, wir alle überhaupt generell. Und jetzt habe ich also, das heißt, ich gehe zu meinem normalen Provider, wo ich auch ein Domain bestellen würde, der dann denjenigen Mitglied ist oder sich selber an ein eins wendet wahrscheinlich. Und der kann dann zudem sagen, okay, ich habe verifiziert, dass diese Rufnummer dem Kunden XY gehört und der darf die jetzt verwenden. Und was macht dann die Denik?
Die Denik freut sich drüber, delegiert diese Domänen an den Nameserver von deinem Provider oder an deinen Nameserver und da hinterlegst du dann die Einträge, die mit der Telefonnummer assoziiert werden sollen.
Das heißt, so wie man eine Webseite registriert, registriert man auch eigentlich seine Telefonnummer. Und das führt dann dazu, dass dann irgendwo eine IP-Adresse steht, die eben das anrufende Telefon herausbekommt in dem Moment, wo man diese Telefonnummer eingibt.
Genau, du kannst da mehr Service-Trips hinterlegen. Du kannst irgendwie sagen, hier hinter der Telefonnummer steckt eine andere Telefonnummer im klassischen Festnetz oder da steckt eine SIP-Adresse dahinter. Beispielsweise 2342.
Also es muss nicht zwangsläufig eine IP-Adresse sich umwandeln lassen?
Das kann alles mögliche sein. Du kannst im Prinzip, ich glaube sogar Job-IDs hinterlegen. Also das ist relativ offen, was man da an...
Das heißt, wenn das eigene Internet-Telefon, IP-Telefon klug genug ist, könnte es dann in Abhängigkeit von der Rufnummer selber bestimmen, wie es irgendwo anruft? Genau. Das sind viele Möglichkeiten. Das wird doch bestimmt wieder nicht funktionieren.
Das ist im Prinzip auch so wie bei Mail. Du kannst auch Prioritäten definieren, dass mit einer höheren Priorität das auf deinem Schreibtisch klingelt. Das ist natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, wenn dein Anbieter dir das dynamisch update. Wenn du zu Hause aus der Haus gehst, drückst du auf die Do Not Disturb-Taste an deinem Telefon. Der Eintrag fährt aus dem DNS. Dafür ist dein Mobiltelefon drin. Mit der Nummer von deinem Mobiltelefon, weil das gerade kein Voice over IP spricht.
Die Flexibilität, die man derzeit eher durch eine Konfiguration der eigenen Telefonanlage oder vielleicht der Voice-Mailbox in der eigenen Mobilfunknummer bei einem Mobilfunkprovider hat, das kann man jetzt in zunehmendem Maße in so einem eigenen Nameserver delegieren. Ah ja, schöne neue Welt. Aber jetzt bleiben wir noch mal bei dem Beispiel. Ich habe also jetzt deine Telefonnummer eingegeben. Und jetzt tun wir mal so, dass das so ist, dass du hinter dieser Telefonnummer die Informationen im Netz platziert hast. Bitte, wenn diese Telefonnummer angewählt wird, dann eine Internet-Telefonie-Verbindung zu meinem Internet-Telefon machen. Das steht jetzt bei dir auf dem Schreibtisch. Und es hat dann eine Adresse.
Genau.
Und die kriegt jetzt mein Telefon raus.
Und was macht das Telefon dann?
Das signalisiert deinem... also dein Telefon sagt meinem Telefon via SIP im Normalfall. Das ist da ein Gespräch.
Was ist SIP?
SIP ist das gebräuchlichste Voice over IP-Protokoll, Session Initiation Protocol. Das ist im Prinzip ein Signalisierungsprotokoll um so Dinge zu übermitteln wie Gesprächswünsche. Es möchte Teilnehmer A mit Teilnehmer B sprechen mit folgender Meta-Information, Rufnummer und so weiter. Erreichbar hier und da.
Das heißt, die beiden Telefonen unterhalten sich jetzt und das ein, mein Telefon erzählt deinem Telefon, was es gerne tun möchte. Es möchte gerne telefonieren. Okay, und dann muss man so viel erzählen.
Ja, man möchte sicher erzählen, was für Kodiks man spricht, was für Metainformationen an dem Gespräch noch mit dranhängen, sowie Rufnummer, gerufene Rufnummer und so weiter.
Kann man ja auch gleich Viren mitschicken.
Ja, kommt auf die Implementation auf der Gegenseite an. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass da noch Spenden auf uns warten.
Was man an der Stelle mal erwähnen sollte, wir reden jetzt hier über Computer. Die heißen dann zwar Telefon und haben Hörer, aber eigentlich sind das kleine Laptops und die haben dann natürlich genau das gleiche Problem wie alle anderen Computer, die im Internet sind. Sie sind direkt erreichbar und müssen sich mit legitimen und dann wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Menge illegitimen Geschichten.
Richtig, also das Nomen, was hier auf dem Tisch steht, da läuft nichts anderes rauf als ein Linux.
Serienmäßig, oder hast du das da selber reingelaufen?
Serienmäßig.
Na gut, das ist schon mal eine Hilfe. Vielleicht, wer weiß. Kodex müssen ausgehandelt werden, um ein Telefonat zu machen. Warum? Warum gibt es da nicht nur einen?
Weil Kodex unterschiedliche Eigenschaften haben. Das ist auch gut so, weil man hat nicht immer Idealbedingungen.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen, Kodex beschreibt das, was das Audio in Daten verwandelt. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt miteinander reden wollen, müssen beide Seiten ja in irgendeiner Form da eine selbe Vorstellung davon haben, wie das Audio in Daten...
Mit den Daten, die ich dir rüber schicke, muss dein Telefon irgendwas anfangen, um das Audio rauszumachen.
Und was nimmt man da?
Das kommt darauf an, was man hat. Also die Frage ist, wie viel Bandbreite steht zur Verfügung? Was für eine Latenz wünscht der User? Und was für eine Gesprächskualität? Da gibt es ganz klassisch G711. Das ist das, was man im ESDN verwendet. A-Law, U-Law mit den 64 Kbps.
Also das normale, was man schon immer benutzt hat.
Das, was im ESDN so gesprochen wird, genau. Da hat man dann inklusive Overhead aus den 64 Kbps, werden dann so was um die 80 Kbps. Wenn man das zur Verfügung hat, kann man sich freuen, kann man darüber schön telefonieren, Latenz ist niedrig, der Minimum Opinion Score, also die Einheit, in der man die Güte der Gesprächsqualität misst.
Was ist das für eine Einheit?
Wie heißt das?
Minimum Opinion Score.
Minimum Opinion Score, genau.
Der durchschnittliche Meinungswert.
Genau.
Was für eine Meinung ist da gefragt?
Da hat man User, die sich das anhören und das dann bewerten dürfen, ob das schlechter oder besser ist.
Das heißt, das ist etwas, was mit Kodex gemacht wird. Die werden irgendwelchen Leuten vorgehalten und die sagen, dann klingt gut, klingt nicht gut.
Genau.
Also so eine rein subjektive Beurteilung, aber dann nimmt man ganz viele Leute. Wer macht das irgendwie?
Ich hab das in dem Kontext schon mal gehört, bei Lucent, die an Hardware vor allem oder an Implementationen von Kodex gearbeitet haben, dass die Leute sitzen haben, die nichts anderes machen die ganzen Tage als telefonieren und Kreuzchen auf Papier.
Aber es gibt doch gar nicht so viele Kodex. Müsste man da nicht irgendwann fertig sein mit? Ich hab hier Mücken.
Ja, das ist nur die Frage der Implementation. Also einen Kodex kann man schön implementieren. Kann man ein bisschen...
Das heißt, man bemüht sich Verbesserungen zu machen und diesen Trade-off zwischen viel Daten werden benötigt und viel Qualität wird benötigt. Man möchte aber eigentlich nicht so viel Daten schicken, weil es muss ja schnell gehen und Daten, die... Ja und so weiter. Verstehe.
Es gibt auch gelegentlich neue Kodex. Also gerade bei GSM hat sich das jetzt ja weiterentwickelt. Da gibt es den AMR. Das ist ein adaptiver Codex, der eben gerade am Antrag von UMTS-Netzen einem den Vorteil bringt, dass man nicht eine fixe Bandbreite reservieren muss, sondern eben gerade die Bandbreite nehmen kann, die man so hat und da dann seine Sprache überwaffen kann. Wenn man weniger Bandbreite hat, dann nimmt man eben weniger Bandbreite, ohne dass es der User jetzt so direkt merkt.
Adaptive Multirate Codec heißt ja dann auch gleich passend. Das wird bei UMTS eingesetzt?
Richtig.
Also in UMTS Telefon-Nutzer, standardmäßig generell? Standardmäßig generell. Ah, okay. Das heißt, UMTS stellt da... Ist das dann eine Verbesserung, eine qualitative, oder ist das nur, dass weniger Daten benutzt werden?
Im Prinzip eine qualitative Verbesserung, weil du eine höhere Anzahl von Usern zufriedenstellen kannst. Wenn du einen Gesprächswunsch hast, im klassischen GSM hast du deine Timeslots, und wenn die aufgebraucht sind, sind die aufgebraucht. Wenn ein User kommt, der einen Gesprächswunsch hat, der nicht befriedigt werden kann, dann...
Okay, also eine Verbesserung für die Dienstgüte des Netzes, weil unter Umständen mehr Leute telefonieren können, aber das klingt jetzt nicht unbedingt deutlich besser.
Das klingt nicht deutlich besser, nee.
Das ist das, woran man so gewöhnt ist. Klingt nach Telefon. Ist auch ein bisschen verwirrend, wenn es nicht nach Telefon klingt. Ich weiß noch, als ESDN eingeführt wurde, das war echt ein Schock, weil auf einmal klang das alles irgendwie so nah. Also man war zum Beispiel gewohnt, dass wenn man nach...
Weiter wegtelefoniert.
Genau, dass es dann einfach schlechter klingt.
So.
Und mit ESDN war das dann immer so alles, als wäre es gleich um die Ecke.
Das speziell.
Da ist der Internet wieder schön. Weil dann klingst du wieder scheiße. Man hört sozusagen jeden Satelliten, der irgendwie noch dazwischen liegt.
Satellit ist ganz kritisch, weil da hat man ja gleich die 600 Millisekunden Latenz drin. Und das macht glaube ich keinen Spaß. Gut, zum Thema Codex, das wollen wir hier mal kurz durchgehen. Es gibt diesen G711, den man so von ISDN her kennt. Dann gibt es natürlich auch Codex mit variabler Bitrate. Beispielsweise G726, den kann man auf 16, 24, 32, 41 Kilobit betreiben. Ist sogar vom Minion Opinion Square ein bisschen höher geratet erstaunlicherweise. Hat auch eine Latenz von 1 Millisekunde. Ist allerdings, wird auch verwendet bei DECT. Also das, was man so von DECT kennt.
Also bei den schnurrlosen Telefonen zu Hause. G726, das G ist dann so ein typischer ITU-Standard, Abkürzungsbuchstabe, der immer vorangestellt wird. Das heißt, ein IP-Telefon kommt eigentlich serienmäßig wahrscheinlich mit mehreren Codex, die es halt unterstützt. Und wenn die beiden Telefone miteinander reden, du sagst, hallo, übrigens, ich hätte hier anzubieten, düs, düs, düs und düs. Und dann eignet man sich auf das Beste.
Oder auf das, was eben gerade der User am Telefon konfiguriert hat, möchte er am besten haben. Dann gibt es noch den G729, der ist bei 8 Kbit. Im Normalfall gibt es auch bei 6,4 und bei 11. Der hat ein bisschen schlechtere Minimum Opinion Score. 25 Millisekunden Latenz, aber eben eine wirklich geringe Bitrate. Das ist gerade bei Providern, die jetzt wirklich viele Voice over IP-Gespräche abwickeln wollen und günstig sein wollen, so das Mittel der Wahl, weil eben die Bandbreite, die aufgewendet werden muss, nicht wirklich groß ist. Nachteil da ist, dass es da urheberrechtliche Geschichte gibt, also der ist patentiert von SIPRO.
Also kein Urheberrechtsproblem, sondern ein Patentproblem.
Denen darf man dann Lizenzgebühr pro Channel zahlen, den man eben G729 encodet.
Das heißt, das Telefon wird wieder teurer, wenn man das alles implementieren möchte, weil man als Hersteller quasi die Lizenzgebühren noch mit in den Produktpreis und dann macht das wieder nicht jeder, und dann kann das nicht jedes Telefon, aber es gibt Anwendungen, wo man das haben möchte.
Das machen Leute, die grausen, offenbar günstiger als den Traffic dafür zu bezahlen.
Ach so, weil man sich einfach Daten spart. Das ist natürlich dann wieder so ein Ding, das man berücksichtigen muss. Man braucht ja auch diese Bandbreite immer dahinter. Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach mal irgendeinen Codec nehmen, der einem so passt, weil unter Umständen reicht deine eigene zuganglich. Also wenn man jetzt einen DSL-Anschluss hat, dann ist das alles zu vernachlässigen. Aber jetzt so über, was du vorhin schon gesagt hast, als Beispiel über UMTS, über GSM, Edge-Netzwerke.
Oder einfach vor allem zwischen Anbietern. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Anbieter hast in, lass es, Uganda sein und da Gespräche hinterminieren möchtest, kostet dich dann natürlich nicht das Mbit Geld, sondern im Prinzip das Kilobit. Also da zahlst du für Traffic ganz andere Preise als innerhalb Europas. Das sind so nicht die 10 Dollar, die man kennt, sondern schon eher das 100- bis 300-fache. In Südafrika ist momentan so preislich für das Mbit, zahlt man da 3000 Dollar. Und da lohnt es sich dann schon wieder, wenn man IP-mäßig runtervermittelt, wirklich Codex zu verwenden, die da sparen, was geht.
Ist ja ein interessanter Punkt. Ist denn Voice over IP für Drittweltländer oder Schwellenländer da eine Chance? Oder ist das noch ein Problem?
Im Prinzip schon, weil man braucht nur, das ist auch einer der Sparfaktoren, die man bei Voice over IP hat, ob man es jetzt im Büro deploit oder als Telco in einem Land, du brauchst nur eine Infrastruktur. Du hast dein IP und du kannst darauf Internet machen, du kannst darauf Telefonie machen. Normalerweise bräuchtest du halt leitungsorientiertes Telefonienetz nochmal, was um einiges teurer kommt, weil du halt dediziert nochmal Leitungen brauchst, weil du Hardware brauchst, die das kann und so stellst du einfach an beide Enden einen Voice over IP-Switch und hast dazwischen dein IP. Was man natürlich dann tun sollte, ist Quality of Service, sprich, dass die Pakete rechtzeitig ankommen, dass die Pakete mit der entsprechenden Priorisierung ankommen, weil jetzt so eine E-Mail doch schon eher warten kann im Gegensatz zu einem Sprachpaket.
Also Quality of Service ist ja so ein selten genutztes Feature im Internetprotokoll. Inwieweit wird denn das bei solchen Interconnect-Verbindungen auch schon berücksichtigt? Da spielt das eine große Rolle, oder?
Das Problem, was wegen Quality of Service im Internet nicht so eine Rolle spielt, ist, dass du im Internet viele Netze hast, die miteinander verbunden sind. Und das Netz übergreifend sinnvoll zu sprechen, ist ein Aufwand. Also das macht keiner mit. Aber in deinem eigenen Netz, was du zu 100% unter deiner administrativen Kontrolle hast, kannst du problemlos das implementieren, wo du möchtest, wo du ganz genau weißt, ich hab hier Quality of Service, hier Quality of Service, hier Quality of Service und leite mein Paket da durch. Im Hintergrund macht man es nicht, weil man sich nicht sicher sein kann, dass das das andere Ende macht. Das ist so eine Hände-Eye-Situation. Im eigenen Netz ist es unerlässlich. Es ist einfach einfach.
Außerdem wollen wir ja Netzneutralität haben. Das kann man ja im eigenen Netz dann entsprechend lassen. Das heißt, es gibt einen Trend ohnehin zur Vereinheitlichung aller Datendienste über Internet. Da ist jetzt Telefonie eigentlich der letzte große Schritt. Weil alles andere, wie Fax und so, das ist ohnehin schon weitgehend aufgesogen worden. Telex schon lange durch E-Mail und so weiter. Und jetzt kommt halt noch Telefon dazu. Jetzt haben wir ja einmal diesen Weg beschrieben von Telefon zu Telefon. Aber bisher telefonieren wir jetzt noch nicht. Gehen wir mal davon aus, die beiden Telefone haben sich jetzt auf einen Codec geeinigt, welcher es auch immer ist. Was passiert dann?
Na dann bauen die Telefone, bauen nicht auf, sondern fangen an, sich über einen RTP-Verbindung Datenpakete entgegenzuwerfen, die Sprache beinhalten.
RTP, neue Abkürzung, das ist das Realtime-Transport-Protokoll, was immer dann genommen wird, wenn es ganz schnell gehen soll. Das heißt, wenn man eine gewisse Kontrolle darüber haben will, wie schnell Daten von A nach B gelangen. Das ist wichtig, damit es nicht abreißt.
Ja, nicht nur eine Kontrolle, sondern ganz einfach. Das ist UDP-basiert und daher relativ lightweight. Du feuerst dein Datagramm raus mit der Sprache drinnen. Dir ist es eigentlich egal, ob es ankommt. Wenn du erfährst, dass es nicht ankommt, ist es eigentlich schon zu spät. Sprache nochmal neu zu übertragen, hat keinen Sinn.
Das macht UDP sowieso. Das ist das Grundprinzip vom Internet. Man schickt erstmal ein Paket hin. Ob es ankommt oder nicht, interessiert keinen.
Ja, bei TCP hast du noch die Rückmeldung, ist das Paket angekommen. Wenn es nicht angekommen ist, sendest du es nochmal. Das ist bei Sprache eigentlich egal. Das ist fair und forget. Du hast einen Datenstrom, der aus dem Telefon rausfällt und in dein Telefon reinläuft.
Das RTP setzt sozusagen auf das UDP auf.
Genau.
Es fügt noch Sachen hinzu wie Betraten, Kontrolle, dass man sich darüber einigen kann. Das wird generell schon verwendet für Videostreaming und eben auch für Audio-Streaming. Das ist bei Telefonen quasi eine einfache Wahl gewesen.
Das ist einfach nur ein Protokoll, der sagt, dieser Datenstrom gehört zu diesem Telefongespräch.
So, und dann fliegen die Daten rüber, und das dann natürlich in beide Richtungen. Das heißt, die beiden Telefone müssen sich direkt miteinander verbinden. Jetzt ist das natürlich so eine Sache. Heutzutage sitzt man ja zu Hause hinter seinem Internetrouter, den man sich bei irgendeiner windigen Firma gekauft hat, nachdem man dann drei Stunden damit zugebracht hat, ihn zu konfigurieren, hat man dann endlich Internet. Aber wie wir ja wissen, ist das mit den Adressen nicht ganz so einfach. Dann hat man da so ein Nut dazwischen. Network Address Translation, das heißt, die IP-Adressen, die ich bei mir zu Hause verwende, haben nichts mit den IP-Adressen zu tun, die hinter meinem Gateway tatsächlich verwendet werden, zumal ich ja auch laufend eine neue zugeteilt bekomme.
Was dann natürlich für siebtes große Problem ist, wenn du ein Telefon hast, da hast du irgendwie gesagt, hm, meine IP ist 192.168, trallala, schick das rüber und das andere Telefon kann damit nichts anfangen, weil, hm, Neil, die IP kenn ich nicht, also ist nicht Internet, ist irgendwie lokales Netz, nicht das Netz hier, da muss man also dann...
Das heißt, das funktioniert alles nicht. Und das war's dann mit Voice over IP Telefonie. Eine schöne Idee für die Zukunft. Es hätte alles wunderbar werden können. Ist ein echtes Problem. Also Nat hat ja schon so einigen die Freude verhagelt. Also das ist ja generell das Problem, wenn ich zu Hause einen Dienst anbieten will, was weiß ich, möchte das hier auf meinen Fallzahler zugreifen. Oder du möchtest, wenn du woanders bist, möchtest darauf zugreifen. Es gibt jetzt ein zunehmendem Maße Protokolle und Produkte, die das unterstützen. Aber bei SIP ist das ein genereller Verhinderer gewesen. Ich meine, du sagst schon, bei dir zu Hause ist eh alles nerdkompatibel. Da hast du sowas gar nicht. Aber das ist natürlich ein Luxus, den nicht jeder hat. Man muss erst mal davon ausgehen, welchen IP-Telefon mir hier zu Hause hinstelle und ich habe einen NAT, dann geht es nicht.
Noch nicht jeder. Das ist die große Hoffnung bei IPv6, dass man, wenn man so viele Adressen hat, auch seinen Telefon zu Hause eine extern erreichbare IP geben kann. Dass du das Telefon am einen Ende hast und die direkt mit den IPs, die sie haben, benutzen, die sie wollen und sich Pakete zuschicken. Die werden anzwischen nur geroutet und nicht nochmal umgelabelt.
Okay, aber es gibt natürlich auch Hoffnung für IPv4. Wir haben ja vorhin schon mal ein bisschen drüber geredet. Das ist jetzt nicht so ganz das Thema dieser Sendung. Aber es gibt ja die neuen NAT-Traversal-Protokolle. Microsoft hat dieses UPNP da gebracht. NAT-PMP ist die Lösung von Apple. Mal gucken, wie das noch so weitergeht. Aber in dem Moment, wo die Telefone so etwas sprechen, können die natürlich da auch durch. Aber dann müssen diese Telefone ja selber diese Telefonnummer registrieren. Geht das auch?
Das Konzept ist einfach, dass das Telefon dem Router sagt, hallo, ich hätte gerne beispielsweise Port 50, 60 auf meine interne IP durchgeleitet. Und dann muss dein Telefon einfach nur noch so schlau sein, der Resip Registry, wo es sich registriert, nicht die interne IP mitzuteilen, sondern die externe IP, die es eben von diesem Router gesagt bekommt. Und wenn das Telefon das beherrscht, und das beherrschen glücklicherweise die meisten Telefone...
Tun sie das?
Na, es gibt da mehrere Ansätze. Es gibt zum einen den jetzt schon besprochen, und dann gibt es STUN, das ist auch so ein Protokoll, was einem da weiterhilft, was einem seine eigene IP verrät, was einem beim Aufbauen von Verbindungen durch den Router durch behilflich ist, auch wenn der Router diese NUT-Trevose-Technologien nicht explizit beharrscht.
Aber das geht ja nicht mit allen NUTs, dieses STUN.
Das geht nicht mit allen NUTs, ja.
Also mit so einem Linux geht das nicht. Wenn man da irgendwie ein symmetrisches NUT hat, dann funktioniert das nicht.
Ja, es gibt verschiedene NUT-Varianten, und das geht halt nicht mit allen, ja.
Genau, und wenn das irgendwie Linux passiert, das geht jetzt nicht, weil das ist immer symmetrisches NUT. Und wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Das weiß ich nicht, ich setze NUT nicht ein.
Na gut, wie auch immer. Also das ist auf jeden Fall nicht so ganz einfach. Ich denke, über kurz oder lang braucht man einfach ein Telefon, das wirklich mit dem Router kommuniziert und sagt, hallo Router, ich bin's, ich bin jetzt das Telefon, ich bin an, ich brauche jetzt einen Port, ich brauche jetzt deine aktuell gültige IP-Adresse und bitte, bitte, bitte, wenn sich die ändert, und auch das passiert ja, teile mir das mit. Und dann kann er dann eben... Aber da muss das Telefon ja selber für diesen DNS-Eintrag sorgen. Also muss es ja selber dafür sorgen, dass das aktuell ist. Machen das die Telefone auch?
In der Regel nicht. Sondern das muss dann wirklich der Service machen, den man nutzt.
Aber es weiß ja nur das Telefon, welcher IP-Adress es gerade hat.
Nee, das weiß auch die Zip-Registry. Weil wenn man nicht eben, wie jetzt besprochen, nur über Enum miteinander telefoniert, sondern über eine Zip-Registry, was in einer Zeit, wo noch nicht jeder einen Enum-Entry hat, sehr sinnvoll ist.
Aha, okay. Neues Kapitel müssen wir jetzt eröffnen. Weil bisher sind wir jetzt ganz naiv davon ausgegangen, dass wir einfach nur zwei Telefone haben, die miteinander reden. Aber die Realität ist etwas komplizierter. Es gibt verschiedene Dienste. Zip-Provider ist, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Klammer, die man da aufmachen kann.
Oder?
So kann man sie nennen. Wie sie alle heißen, fallen uns mehr als fünf ein. Dann können wir anfangen, irgendwelche zu nennen. Also Zipgate waren, glaube ich, ziemlich weit vorne. Von daher kann man die da mal nennen. Das sind also einfach Dienstleister, bei denen man Internet-Telefonie-Dienste bekommt. Und man kriegt dafür dann einen Account. Das heißt, das Telefon wird nicht so konfiguriert, dass es selber direkt im Internet lauscht.
Sondern dass es einfach eine Telefonnummer wählt.
Es lockt sich ein.
Es lockt sich dort ein, nutzt seine User-Daten, wählt eine Telefonnummer dort drüber. Und dort wird dann entschieden, geht das dazu über IP weiter, geht das ins Festnetz, wohin auch immer. Die haben da im Prinzip einen Zip-Switch und ein Gateway stehen, also eine Zip-Registry, ein Sub-Gateway und unsere Proxy. Und können da eben ihre User registriert haben und die Gespräche entgegennehmen und ins Festnetz terminieren.
Genau, das ist natürlich schon mal ein Vorteil. Man macht dann nicht mehr nur Voice over IP, sondern das sind im Prinzip Gateways, die sich auch mit den bestehenden Telefonnetzen verbinden lassen. Das heißt, ich bekomme eine Telefonnummer zugeteilt von diesem Provider in dem Moment, wo ich mir dann Account klicke und bin dann anrufbar. Das heißt, diese Telefonnummer gibt es dann auch in dem normalen Telefonnetz. Sprich, die haben da so ein Nummerpaket bei der Telekom oder wo muss man sich das beantragen heutzutage?
Das kriegt man von der Regulierungsbehörde bzw. von der Bundesnetzagentur.
Genau, und Bundesnetzagentur, das ist auch echt ein super Wort. Das hat Klang behördlicher, oder?
Für Post und Telekommunikation.
Jawoll, jetzt ist es so eine Netzagentur. Jetzt hat man das Gefühl, dass man da wie in so einem Callcenter. Wir haben jetzt Kunden. Okay, also die Bundesnetzagentur vergibt Telefonnummernblöcke, diese SIP-Provider kaufen sich welche und stellen dann diese Nummern en masse interessierten Kunden zur Verfügung, kostenlos oder auch nicht. Häufig gibt es da so Schnupperangebote, lass dich doch schon mal anrufen, dann kannst du dein Telefon zu Hause hinstellen, bist anrufbar über eine Nummer. Aber wenn du halt über uns wieder raustelefonieren willst, also wenn du auch in die andere Richtung telefonieren willst, dann musst du halt bezahlen. Dann ist das im Prinzip so wie mein Festnetzanschluss zu Hause. Aber eigentlich bräuchte man keinen mehr. Man kann sich irgendwo eine neue Wohnung suchen, dann zieht man da ein, stellt sein Telefon auf den Tisch, gibt ihm Internet und ist wieder erreicht. Na, man braucht erstmal Internet. Aber man kann sozusagen Internet sich kaufen ohne Telefon. Das gibt es zwar heute schon im Doppelpark, weil das natürlich auch eine gute Möglichkeit ist, Geld zu verdienen. Aber im Prinzip bräuchte man nur Internet, stelle ich das Telefon da hin und dann habe ich halt meinen Provider, den ich auch vorher schon hatte und alles ist sofort wie es vorher war. Und wie umgeht man da? Na, ist das dann irgendwie anders?
Das ist im Prinzip dasselbe.
Das Problem ist auch immer noch dasselbe.
Das Problem ist dasselbe und da hat man halt den Stun-Server oder was auch immer bei seinem Provider stehen. Der hat halt dann damit irgendwie hier Subject History Server, da Stun-Server, da trägt man sein Telefon ein.
Genau, dieses Stun oder S-Tun, das haben wir nämlich noch gar nicht erwähnt. Das ist ja ein System, was Natt versucht zu, naja, so zu penetrieren, so zu penetrieren, dass es auch von außen erreichbar ist. Ich muss schon sagen, es gibt viele verschiedene Natt-Systeme. Eigentlich müsste man glaubt mal eine Sendung über Natt machen. Mit nicht allen geht das, aber mit den meisten. Dazu ist aber ein externer Server nötig.
Genau, es nutzt ja die Eigenschaften von Natt, was eben Connections auch offen lässt. Also wenn ich jetzt Pakete mit jemandem im Internet austausche, auch wenn das nicht verbindungsorientiert wie bei TCP ist, muss das Natt einem die Pakete trotzdem weiterverwenden. Und das nutzt im Prinzip diese Eigenschaft von Natt aus, um zu simulieren, dass da ein Datenstrom wäre, der dann eben im Prinzip nur für das Signaling benutzt wird, wenn gerade ein Anruf reinkommt. Das Wichtige ist ja nicht das Raustelefonieren, das geht auf jeden Fall, sondern das Reintelefonieren, dass ein paar Klienten ankommen und du bekommst einen Anruf, dass das auch zum Telefon findet.
Genau, also solange die Telefone noch nicht aktiv mit dem Router kommunizieren, ich sag mal voraus, das wird jetzt bald stattfinden, weil die ganzen Methoden mit S-Tonen und was da eigentlich noch alles erdacht wurde, es funktioniert einfach nicht zuverlässig. Die Erfahrung ist immer wieder, es gibt dann immer irgendein Problem und nichts nervt so sehr wie ein Telefon, wo man...
Was nicht klingelt, wenn man dann ruft.
Was nicht klingelt, genau. Oder was noch nicht mal tutmacht, weil, was weiß ich. Und das ist einfach blöd. Und das ist auch nicht das, was man gewöhnt ist. Also nichts, die Dienstgüter...
Nee, das ist eben genau das Telefon, das was, wo man abhebt und benutzen kann. Das was, wo man Notrufe abwickeln kann, was man einfach verfahren durch die Stars.
Genau, muss so klingen, wie der Chaosradio-Jingle am Anfang. Klick, tüüüt, so. Das hat man nicht.
Wobei ich meine Hoffnung ja immer noch auf IPv6 setze. Also ich hoffe, dass wir das Problem in zehn Jahren einfach dadurch nicht mehr haben, weil jeder IPv6 hat und weil die...
Zehn Jahren! In zehn Jahren sind wir alle schon vaporisierte Atome und treiben irgendwie durchs Weltall.
Aber wir können telefonieren.
Gut, also das heißt aber, dass dieses S-Tone-Protokoll meistens noch mit konfiguriert werden muss. Das heißt, wenn man sein Telefon einrichtet, ist es eben nicht nur dieses Login-Passwort und Server, wo dieser Login abgesetzt wird, sondern man muss auch noch, damit überhaupt die Kommunikation zuverlässig funktionieren kann, diesen S-Tone-Server und den dazugehörigen Port noch mit angeben. Dann allerdings sind die Chancen relativ groß, dass es klappt. Also mit den meisten Rotern, die man so ab Werk kauft, also aus dem Laden kauft, die sind ab Werk so, dass sie das können, weil es heute auch schon von ihnen erwartet wird, dass sie das können. Gut, ich will mich jetzt nicht zu lange mit diesen Nat-Sonderheiten, ich bin da ein bisschen obssessed, was Nat betrifft. Ich finde es wirklich schlimm. IPv6, was du schon erwähnt hast, ich bin da nicht ganz so optimistisch, dass sich das so schnell durchsetzt. In 10 Jahren. Gut, aber 10 Jahre ist echt kein Zeitraum, über den man reden sollte.
Die IPv4-Adressen werden uns bis 2010, 2011 ausgegangen sein, wenn es da nicht noch kluge Reservepläne gibt. Wenn man sich anguckt, die Deutsche Telekom hat seit vielen Jahren 3, 4 IPv6-Testungen. Wikipedia, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ich hoffe, ich plaudere jetzt da nichts aus, ist daran, sich IPv6 genauer anzusehen, hat da schon...
Für Ihre Serverinfrastruktur. Warum haben die da Interesse daran?
Weil es einfach kommen wird und wir so sich später damit beschäftigen, wenn man sich jetzt damit beschäftigen kann, zu deployen.
Gut, aber es gibt jetzt nichts Spezifisches bei Wikipedia. Ich meine, das ist ja nur ein Web-Server, das ist ja nur wirklich problemlos zu erreichen. Es geht ja ums Prinzip.
Man muss ja anfangen, wenn kein Content da ist, dann gibt es keinen User.
Na gut, ich meine, es gibt viele Web-Server, die durchaus über IPv6 zu erreichen sind. Das ist ja nicht so das Ding. Das große Problem ist, IPv6 zu Hause zu haben, mit modernen Rautern. Kluge Rauter machen das so, dass die halt selber einen Tunnel aufsetzen, dass man auch IPv6 zu Hause hat. Und dann ist man in der Regel auch ganz gut von innen erreichbar. Aber das geht auch mit IPv5. Aber das soll jetzt nicht unser Thema sein, sondern wir wollen über Telefone reden und nicht über IPv6. Ich bin mir sicher, IPv6 sollte das Thema sein einer kommenden Chaosradio-Sendung. Hab ich auch schon auf meiner Liste. Aber ich hab bisher noch nicht wirklich einen Plan gefasst, das dann auch mal zu machen. Kommt aber. So, jetzt haben wir also diese Sache mit, ich hab da so meinen Provider und ich konfigurier meine Telefone. Das heißt, ich kann mir dann auch so mehrere Telefone auf den Tisch stellen, die alle unter irgendeiner Rufnummer zu erreichen sind. Aber das ist ja eigentlich nicht das, was man normalerweise haben will. Man will ja eigentlich eine Telefonanlage haben, weil wenn ich da drüben einen Tisch stehen habe und hier hab ich einen Tisch stehen habe und da sitzt jeweils ein Telefon, dann möchte ich natürlich die Nummer 2 drücken. Dann klingelt es drüben. So Tischtelefon mit Nationalfähnchen irgendwie auf dem Tisch. Und so, hallo, wer bist du denn?
Wenn ich das nebenan klingel, dann kann man es ja mal kennenlernen.
Wie macht man denn das? Geht das auch?
Das geht, ja.
Und was brauche ich dafür? Da kaufe ich mir eine Telefonanlage mit VoIP. Gibt's, ne?
Ja, kann man sich kaufen, kann man aber auch selber machen.
Und was kann man, also wenn man sich so kauft, fällt dir da aus dem Kopf irgendwas rein, was vielleicht auch tatsächlich funktioniert? Fällt dir irgendwas ein, was nicht funktioniert und behauptet, es würde funktionieren?
Ja, das Problem ist, dass es da draußen sehr viele Linux-basierte, Linux- und Asterisk-basierte Telefonanlagen gibt, die vorgeben, ISDN zu sprechen. Allerdings, wenn man sich so um diese ganzen ISDN-Implementierungen, die es für Linux da so gibt, ansieht, mit denen man Voice over IP betreiben kann, dann wird man sehr schnell feststellen, dass das zwar theoretisch möglich ist, aber so im täglichen Betrieb schon so seine Ecken und Kanten hat. Ich habe selbst mehrere Kunden, die so Systeme einsetzen und die sind alle zufrieden, dass es so halbwegs funktioniert. Man muss es einmal im Monat irgendwie gegen treten, aber so richtig glücklich wird man damit noch nicht.
Das heißt, auch wenn man jetzt hier, was weiß ich, gibt es ja so Fritz-Box und so ein Kram, die auch schon mit VoIP-Funktionalität aufweisen.
Das geht noch halbwegs, weil sie da eigene Hardware designt haben und auch speziell die Implementation dafür. Also das ist relativ solide.
Aber was machen denn diese Teile? Nehmen die VoIP, damit ich sozusagen über Ethernet mein Telefon anschließen kann, so wie ich auch alle anderen?
Sowohl das auch. Du kannst über so eine Fritz-Box, so genannt, sowohl ISDN in beide Richtungen haben. Also du kannst einen ISDN-Anschluss anschließen und auf der anderen Seite ein ISDN-Telefon haben. Dazwischen sagt die Box eben, für bestimmte Rufnummern werde ich über VoIP raus. Das Ding weist sich ins Internet ein und hat dann irgendwie seinen Web-Account und wickelt über den dann Stimpelgespräche ab. Wenn du beispielsweise Festnetzgespräche über die sogenannte SIP-Gate terminieren möchtest oder Mobilfunkgespräche über ISDN, kann man das mit so einer Box relativ out of the box machen.
Braucht man halt nur ein Voice over IP-Telefon dafür?
Nee, mit einem normalen ISDN-Telefon.
Die Telefoniererei geht dann nicht mehr über ISDN oder worüber man auch mal angeschlossen ist, sondern dann eben übers Internet. Und als Telefonanlagenersatz, also kann ich dann auch ein Voice over IP-Telefon nehmen und das dann irgendwie anschließen? Oder ist das was anderes?
Das tut sicherlich auch.
Wir reden über Sachen, von denen wir nichts verstehen. Willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Aber wir wollten ja eigentlich darüber reden, wie es funktioniert und vor allem, wie man das selber machen kann. Das sind natürlich jetzt solche vorgefertigten Produkte gar nicht unser Thema. Wir wissen jetzt auch nicht wirklich, wie gut oder zufällig das funktioniert. Und wie langweilig das ist, genau.
Da kriegt man so eine Box, wo jemand was zusammengebastelt hat nach seiner Vorgabe. Der Kunde braucht wahrscheinlich das. Man kann gerade bei Voice over IP sehen, der Vorteil, dass man da so viele verschiedene bunte Dinge hat, die man aneinanderkleben kann. Frank Rohr hat das, glaube ich, mal bezeichnet, als wie Eisenbahnen spielen, nur man kann damit telefonieren.
Okay, Internet, Eisenbahn, Telefonie. Wie funktioniert das? Wir haben das Zauberwort ja schon genannt. Asterisk ist eine sehr bekannte und verbreitete Software-Paket. Auch Open Source, schön frei, zum Runterladen, was viele Leute benutzen, um sich solche Voice over IP und auch andere Telefonanlagensysteme zu realisieren. Das ist nicht nur Voice over IP, sondern generell eine computerbasierte Telefonie-Lösung. D.h., ich kann einen Rechner nehmen, kann den Software drauf spielen und habe Telefonanlagen-Funktionalität. Ich kann mich an ISDN und analoge Anlagen anschließen, wenn ich die entsprechende Hardware in den Rechner reingesteckt bekomme.
Sogar nicht mal allzu teuer. Der Vorteil ist, die Karten, die man da reinsteckt, mit denen man sowohl NT- als auch TE-Mode, sprich Telefone, als auch Netz anschließen, die sind so einfach aufgebaut, also andersrum. Die Karten, mit denen das funktioniert, die sind relativ einfach aufgebaut. Aktive ISDN-Karten, die den ganzen Kram in einem Chip machen, will man an der Stelle eigentlich gar nicht haben, weil man mit denen nicht so viel spielen kann. Und das sind die teuren. Die günstigen, mit denen man dann viel in Software macht, sind eigentlich die, die man da haben möchte. Da zahlt man zwischen 10 und 20 Euro für einen ISDN-Port. Und das kann man sich auch mal zum Basteln leisten.
Man braucht bloß einen Rechner, wo man viele Karten reinstecken kann. Weil man braucht ja dann irgendwie S0-Karten. Davon reden wir jetzt, wo wir die Telefonie direkt anschließen können. Aber, ja, ich meine, wie funktioniert das jetzt? Die Software läuft unter Linux. Läuft sie eigentlich nur unter Linux?
Nein. Nee, ein guter Freund von mir betreibt das auf FreeBSD und ist damit halbwegs zufrieden.
Okay, hatten wir ja vor kurzem hier bei Chaosradio Express das Thema. Falls dich jemand für FreeBSD interessiert. Aber Linux ist so ein bisschen der Home-Turf der Software. Und da wird es auch meistens zum Einsatz gebracht. Insbesondere, wenn es um Hardware geht. Weil da hat man natürlich noch ein anderes Problem. Nämlich die Sache mit dem Hardware-Support und ISDN-Karten. Und FreeBSD ist glaube ich nicht so toll. Wie sieht denn das bei Linux so aus?
Das besteht auch Hoffnung, was die ISDN-Implementation angeht. Ich hätte mich mit Carsten Kail unterhalten, der momentan an dem ISDN arbeitet. Und was ich da gesehen habe, also warten wir mal ein, zwei Jahre, dann wird das auch noch ein bisschen stabiler werden.
Ach, noch mal zwei Jahre warten. Ich warte schon ganz schön lange darauf, dass diese ISDN-Geschichte ein bisschen einheitlicher behandelt wird. Bei Linux scheint aber noch nicht so weit zu sein. Bei ISDN ist dieser jüngste Vorstoß gewesen, das Ganze alles halbwegs geordnet ablaufen zu lassen.
Vor allem eben modular. Das ist das, was man bei diesen ganzen Voice over IP-Geschichten hat. Vor allem einfach ein Asterisk. Modularität. Du nimmst die Dinge, die du brauchst, klebst sie dir so zusammen, wie du es gerne hättest, und machst das damit, was du damit tun möchtest.
Ja, wie mache ich denn das jetzt? Also angenommen, ich möchte jetzt eine Telefonanlage zu Hause haben. Und dann möchte ich meine Voice over IP-Telefone an diese Anlage anschließen.
Ein Schloss zu Hause und Callhandling damit machen. Das ist im Prinzip einfach. Also runterladen, compilieren, konfigurieren, läuft.
Echt? Also ich hab mir neulich meine Distribution runtergeladen, die bootet dann auch nicht mal.
Ja, es gibt so Distributionen, die man sich runterladen kann, installieren kann. Da kriegt man halt ein vorgefertigtes System. Das ist zum Reinschnuppern vielleicht ganz nett. Man kann ein bisschen drauf rumklicken. Er sieht bunt aus. Das funktioniert vielleicht auch sogar auf der Hardware, die man da gerade hat. Oder eben auch nicht. Und in der VM, was ist denn halt die Frage? Wollt ihr euch bei dir in der Falle...
Ja, kann auch daran gelegen haben. Will ich jetzt gar nicht auf die Software machen. Aber vielleicht sagen wir noch mal kurz so ein bisschen erläutern. Also welche Struktur hat diese Software? Was macht Asteres genau?
Na, du hast an Asteres mehrere für Voice over IP notwendige Services. Du hast zum einen den SIP-Proxy, der im Prinzip zwischen den Usern SIP-Messages austauscht, mit den Usern SIP spricht.
Welchen Usern?
Den Telefon? Den Telefon, genau.
Okay, das heißt mein tolles IP-Telefon, was wir hier von Anfang an einmal zitiert haben, geht jetzt nicht zu irgendeinem Provider und sagt, hallo, ich lock mich ein und nutze deine Dienste für mehr oder weniger Geld, sondern es lockt sich jetzt an dem Asteroid-Server an und sagt, hallo, ich bin dein IP-Telefon, verfüge über mich.
Das hat eine Zip-Registry und da steht dann drin, der und der User hat gerade die und die IP und die Eigenschaften.
Das heißt, das Telefon als solches autorisiert sich auch, ich kann das Telefon irgendwo anders hinstellen und man weiß immer noch, dass das selbe Telefon ist, das heißt, ich kann mein Telefon mitnehmen, an einen anderen Tisch stellen und so weiter. Es ist nicht mehr relevant, über welche Dose es angeschlossen ist.
Du musst das Telefon auch nicht stellen. Also gerade Nokia ist da frischend flott dabei, Voice over IP-Functionalität gerade in die Businessgeräte zu bringen. Also diese Nokia E-Series, wie du hier eins auf den Tisch legen lässt und ich auch, so E61, E90, die haben einen Voice over IP-Client drin, der das WLAN nutzt und SIP spricht. Also du kannst da irgendwie deinen Account, den du dir im Astara Scan gelegt hast, in dieser Konfigurationsdatei, an einer SIP.conf kannst du dir dein Telefon eintragen, das Telefon bei einem Astaris registrieren und dann biete dir dein Telefon an, wenn du eine Nummer gewählt hast.
Make Internet Call, nicht über WLAN. Wenn man ins WLAN reinkommt.
Wenn man ins WLAN reinkommt.
Ist ja nicht so einfach bei diesem Telefon. Und das heißt, für das Astaris sind dann alle angeschlossenen SIP-Telefone, es gibt halt einfach N-Nebenstellen. Und dann kann ich aber auch von der einen zu anderen telefonieren.
Genau.
Und wie konfigurier ich mich da jetzt? Also was muss ich jetzt tun, um da Nummern zu vergeben für diese Telefone?
Das ist so aufgebaut, dass du da eine ganze Handvoll Konfigurationsfiles hast. Astaris bietet einem auch an, wenn man nach dem Compile ein Make Examples oder Make Samples macht, dann kostet es einem da erst mal einen Haufen Beispielkonfigurationen hin, wo man dann verschiedene Dinge testen kann. Im Prinzip hast du deine zip.conf, in der stehen deine Teilnehmer drin, also deine User, für die zip registry. Dann hast du deine extensions.conf, wo du im Prinzip deinen Dialplan definierst. Da sagst du, wenn der User eine Rufnummer wählt, die mit Null anfängt, dann wähle raus über ISDN Festnetz, weil wir da gerade eine Flatrate haben. Wenn der User eine Rufnummer mit Null eins wählt, dann sagt dem User, wenn er nicht die Privilegien hat, dass Mobilfunk und Senderrufnummern böse sind. Wenn der User die Privilegien hat, dann darf er rauswählen über die nächste Inanschluss. Wenn eine Null gewählt wird, dann geht es raus über Zipgate, weil die irgendwie Ausland für günstig anbieten. Man kann sich eigentlich seinen Teilplan so persönlich zuschneidern, wie man möchte. Man kann selber Nummern vergeben.
Das heißt, das sind auch im Wesentlichen diese beiden Dateien, mit denen man zu kämpfen hat. Kompliziert sind die im typischen Konfigurations-Datei-Wald, den man so bekämpfen muss?
Das ist erfrischend, übersichtlich. Dafür sind auch die Samples da. In den Samples sieht man relativ schnell, wie die Struktur ist. Da hast du ja halt irgendwie diesen netter eckige Klammer auf, Username, eckige Klammer zu und drunter eben Eigenschaften, Caller, ID gleich eins, zwei, drei, Username gleich vier, fünf, sechs, Type gleich friend, Kontext eben besagter Kontext, indem er dann in diesem Dialplan wieder auftaucht. Da gibt es auch ein Wiki dazu.
Wollt man wahrscheinlich auch, weil Konfigurations-Sateien sind natürlich jetzt nicht jedermanns Sache. Gibt es das auch in Bund? So mit Klicken und so?
Das gibt es natürlich auch in Bund. Das sind dann besagte fertige Distributionen, wie jetzt Tricksbox zum Beispiel, Emails, Astros, Get Home, die man sich einfach auf einer Maschine installiert, die ein Web-Interface haben, wo man schön klicken kann. Das hat man natürlich auch bei diesen kommerziellen Astros-Boxen, die man sich kaufen kann. Web-Interface dabei, wo man seine User anlegen kann, wo man irgendwie sagen kann, Anrufgruppe, wenn die Nummer gewählt wird, dann klingen die Telefone der Reihe nach und so weiter. Es hat auch so Applikationen in diesem Astros-Gren, wie Voice-Mail, auf das du verweisen kannst. Du kannst Konferenzen bauen, Konferenzräume. Du hast Warteschleifen. Du kannst auch so klassische AVRs machen, also interaktive Sprachsysteme. Drücken sie die eins, wenn sie sprechen wollen mit. Drücken sie die zwei, wenn sie weiter warten wollen. Drücken sie die drei.
Wenn sie schon kurz davor sind, dass ihnen die Nerven durchgehen und drücken sie 100-mal die fünf, wenn sie alles nicht mehr tragen können. Man kann sich den Neuens-Faktor auch selber einbauen.
Nach dem Motto, please press any key to continue, please press any other key to wait another 5 minutes.
Und wie schnell muss ein Computer sein, damit das Ganze auch vonstatten geht? Ist Asteros der Rechner?
Wenn es für privat zu Hause ist, zu der Hardware von gestern oder vorgestern greifen, also alles mit 800 MHz, 1 GHz und mehr, reicht völlig aus für die 2, 3 Gesprächchen, die man da so hat. Für ISDN-Terminierungen, das war allerdings mit einer aktiven ISDN-Karte, die einem einiges abgenommen hat, hatte ich zu Hause irgendwie einen, ich wüsste jetzt, Lügen-P, ein Penschen MMX mit 233 MHz, so stand noch rum, Karte reingeworfen, mal geguckt, ob es funktioniert. Und der hat eben seine 2 Gesprächskranelle ins ISDN terminiert und war zufrieden.
Okay, aber dann auch, also das war dann nur ISDN sozusagen?
Das war dann nur ISDN-Termination.
Das heißt, aber in dem Moment, wo man Voice over IP macht, dann steigt natürlich der CPU-Bedarf, weil da ist alles in Software stattfindet?
Ja, das war ISDN mit G7, 11-Kodec und wirklich Planen, ISDN nach Voice over IP. Sobald man so Sperenzchen hat wie Voice-Mail oder Warteschleifen, wo man MP3s dann decodiert und den Leuten vorspielt, und das nicht nur für eine Warteschleife, sondern gleich für fünf, sechs verschiedene, dann würde man schon eine Maschine mit mehr Rums drunter.
Mehr Rums. Jetzt gibt es ja auch eine ganze Menge Alternativprojekte, die sich so aus diesem, was heißt eine ganze Menge, mir fällt jetzt aus dem Stand natürlich nur eins ein, Coilweaver, was auch mal anders hieß, glaube ich.
Hieß früher Open PBX, da gab es aber, glaube ich, Markenrechtsprobleme. Die Sache ist halt die, Asterisk ist ein Produkt im Prinzip von Digium. Es steht zwar unter der GPL, aber es ist ganz stark dadurch geprägt, dass Digium auch Karten herstellt, ESDN-Karten, Analog-Karten. Und Digium hat auf diesen Karten beispielsweise, das klassische Beispiel fürs Timing spezielle Hardware, dass das Timing eingehalten wird, dass Pakete zu richtigen Zeitpunkt. Also man braucht, wenn man so eine Software hat, eben akkordantes Timing.
Das heißt, man muss die Karten bei Digium kaufen, oder was?
Sprich, wenn du ESDN sauber terminieren möchtest, dann brauchst du dir am besten die Karte von Digium. Die Sache ist jetzt die, dass du dieses Timing nicht nur in der Implementation, wie es jetzt Asterisk ist, im User-Space machen könntest, sondern auch im Kern. Du kannst bei der Kern eine akkuratere Timing, so was dir zur Verfügung stellen kann, naturgemäß. Wenn man jetzt an Digium herantritt, mit einem Patch, der genau dies tut, dann wird Digium einem sagen, schön, ja, ne, nehmen wir nicht auf.
Würde oder hat getan?
Hat getan, weil wir wollen unsere Karten verkaufen, als Argument.
Das heißt, die verbessern die Software nicht?
Wenn es ihre Hardware schon tut.
Weil die Hardware macht mehr Geld. Und damit waren nicht alle so glücklich?
Damit waren nicht alle so glücklich. Und auch mit dem ewigen Hin und Her. Es gab einige Änderungen bei Asterisk, die dazu geführt haben, dass Konfigurationsweisen mit der einen Version nicht mehr funktionieren, dass man das umwandeln muss und so weiter.
Ohne, dass es einfache Konverter gab?
Ja, gab's schon, aber das Problem war, dass man nicht an vorhandenen Fehlern gearbeitet hat. Da sind neue Features und so weiter. Das will man besser zu kennen, wenn Software kommerziell entwickelt wird und User dahinter stehen, die keine Features sehen, denen die Stabilität dann weniger. Da ist im Ansatz von Coilwiefer gewesen, zu sagen, wir machen das Ganze mal sauber, Feature Freeze und das Ganze aufgeräumt. Das ist dazu auch schon relativ weit fortgeschritten. Also ich setze für AS250 einen Coilwiefer ein und bin damit relativ zufrieden.
Was ist das, AS250?
Das ist ein Projekt von mir, wo ich versuche, Open Source und Community-Projekte, Infrastruktur zur Verfügung zu stellen. Sei es Server oder Voice over IP.
Das bittest du Dritten an?
Das bitte ich Open Source und Community-Projekten an. Wie beispielsweise theyesman.org.
Jaja, die Jungs sind toll.
Das dachte ich mir auch. Sie hatten das Problem, wir haben keinen Server mehr, weil Exxon gemeint hat, wir sind böse. Unser ESP meinte, Exxon ist groß und nicht so schön.
Und was haben die bei dir bekommen?
Ich hab einfach mal ein Server vom Stapel genommen und den E-Mail geschrieben. Jungs, da Zugangsdaten, viel Spaß.
Und dann benutzen die SIP oder was?
Die haben den Server für E-Mail.
Das ist nicht nur Community-Projekte für Telefonieinfrastruktur.
Vor allem, wenn Leute was in die Hand drücken.
Aber du hast auch Telefonieinfrastruktur und du würdest dir auch Telefonieinfrastruktur bereitstellen?
Ja, sehr gerne.
Und das läuft mit Call Weaver. Ist das von der Konfiguration groß anders oder ist das im Prinzip dasselbe in grün?
Das ist im Prinzip genau dasselbe in grün. Man findet sogar bisweilen noch Kommentare, in denen Digium oder Asterisk referenziert ist. Also alles, was sie nicht mit Search and Replay erwischt haben. Also ist im Prinzip wirklich eins zu eins der GPL-Decode von Digium genommen und eben schön sauber aufgeräumt.
Und du kannst das empfehlen? Gibt es noch weitere Sachen, die man empfehlen kann oder sollte?
Zumindest mal nennen sollte. Es gibt CER, das ist ein SIP-Express-Router. Das ist ein reiner SIP-Router, also ein reiner SIP-Proxy.
Was heißt das? Also im Vergleich zu Colvi von Asteris tut es was nicht?
Das stellt keinerlei Funktionalität, wie jetzt ISDN-Terminierung usw. Oder Mailboxen haben sie, glaube ich, auch nicht. Voice Mail ist halt wirklich nur, um SIP-Gespräche zu vermitteln. Und wenn man das Problem auf so eine kleine Sache eingrenzen kann, wie SIP-Gespräche zu vermitteln, hat man natürlich mehr Zeit, den Code zu optimieren und das Ganze rein in C zu schreiben.
Das heißt, das sind im Prinzip schon Projekte, die ein bisschen der Zeit voraus sind und sagen, wir haben jetzt auch überhaupt keine alten Geräte mehr, die wir noch unterstützen und anbinden müssen. Also weder haben wir ein ISDN-Telefon oder ein Analog-Telefon, noch benutzen wir ISDN und Analog-Zugänge. Sondern alles ist irgendwie Internet. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich erst dann so richtig der Hit werden, wenn man wirklich zuverlässige IP-Telefone hat, die auch billig sind. Und da gibt es glaube ich noch nicht so richtig viel, oder? Gibt es so ein heißes Eisen, was man unbedingt haben muss? Ich habe mir mal so ein Ding gekauft hier, keine Ahnung, wie hieß das?
Wahrscheinlich das GXP 2000, was ich da vorhin... Grandstream.
Genau, so ein Grandstream. Tralala BT101 oder sowas. Und das... Naja, also ich meine, das hat noch nicht mal Verschlüsselung. Das hat noch was dazusagen, also bei SIP geht ja Verschlüsselung, aber es geht auch keine Verschlüsselung. Da muss man schon gut drauf achten, was man da auf seinem Telefon hat, sonst schickt man die Passwörter.
Ich habe mich gefreut, wie ich als kleines Kind dieses Snom gesehen habe, dass das Out-of-the-Box-SRTP kann. Ich habe mich vorher mit Verschlüsselung und SIP noch gar nicht so...
Weißt du, was du gesehen hast? Auch hier dieses Snom-360-Telefon.
Genau, das ist ziemlich featurekomplit. Die haben sich da echt Mühe gegeben, auch die Konfigurierbarkeit. Die Konfigurierbarkeit liegt momentan bei 150 Euro.
Aber dafür gibt es viele Tasten.
Man hat viele Tasten. Es wird in großer Stütze hergestellt. Das ist bei einigen Kunden schon eingesetzt, die ganz zufrieden damit sind. Ich glaube, das D6 setzt das Ding auch ein. Da ist auch SATP und es zeigt dir ein offenes Schlösschen an im Display, wenn du gerade Unverschlüsse telefonierst. Das Problem allerdings, was sich stellt, das zeigt mir mal bitte eine SATP-Implementation.
Eine was?
Eine Implementation von SATP.
Also wo der Datenstrom selber secure ist?
Ja, so ein SIP-Proxy, der das kann, oder ein Gateway.
Gibt es das überhaupt?
Ich hab bisher noch, also darf man mich gerne korrigieren, noch keine Implementation gesehen.
Du meinst also generell gibt es einfach noch überhaupt keine Option, Voice over IP verschlüsselt durchzuführen?
Überhaupt keine, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber interoperabel schon mal nicht. Und es ist ähnlich wie mit IPv6 bei Asterisk. Also es gibt da zwar ein IPv6 Projekt für Asterisk, aber das ist weder benutzbar noch in irgendeiner Form reif. Also dass man jetzt sagen kann, okay, kommt demnächst, kann man einsetzen.
Das ist aber nicht in der Diskussion, oder was?
Das ist scheinbar kein gewünschtes Feature. Das ist allerdings, sehe ich gerade bei CER, also bei diesem Sub-Express-Router, die haben Support für V4 und V6. Und das in einem Memory-Footprint von 300 bis 600 Kilobyte.
Dann könnte man, wenn man V6 hat, nicht auch gleich verschlüsseltes IP benutzen?
Theoretisch.
Praktisch müsste das dann auch erst mal realisiert werden. Das heißt, wenn man Voice over IP macht im Netz, dann ist man unverschlüsselt unterwegs.
Dann ist man größtenteils unverschlüsselt unterwegs.
Das heißt, man kann an jedem Router die Absprecher-Taste drücken und schon ist das Telefongespräch auf Platte.
Sollten wir vielleicht im Kongress mal so als Proof of Concept anlaufen, Full Interception?
Wir hören jetzt einfach mal ab. Na gut, auf dem Kongress wird kommt ja ein weitgehend deckt zum Einsatz. Das ist jetzt mal ein bisschen verschlüsselt.
So ein bisschen, ja.
Aber das, was nach draußen geht...
Das geht auch über Voice over IP nach draußen.
Das heißt, das könnte man dann einfach mal broadcasten und auf die Lautsprecher im Gang werfen. Ja, ich glaube, da würden sich einige Leute wundern. SIP-Express-Router gibt es schon ein bisschen länger. Dann gibt es aber auch noch mal so eine Open-Variante davon. Das ist, glaube ich, auch wieder so ein Ableger, nicht? Dieses Open-Server.
Da gibt es auch auf dem Kongress einen Vortrag, habe ich gesehen, zu...
Auf dem 24C3. Auf jeden Fall auch noch hier bald ein Thema bei Chaosradio Express. Dann können wir das vorstellen. Okay, also Voice over IP auch auf dem Kongress ein Thema.
Was ich noch sagen wollte zum Thema Security. Bei den Snowm370s, habe ich gesehen, haben sie im Featureset erfrischenderweise OpenVPN. Also sie gehen das Problem anders an. Sie sagen, wir verschlüsseln das IP drunter. Und das könnte ich mir sogar vorstellen. Also da kenne ich einige Use-Cases bei Kunden, die ganz glücklich darüber werden, wenn sie so ein Telefon hätten, in dem das IP was drin ist, irgendwie einmal in ein VPN fällt und auf der anderen Seite auf dem...
Das heißt, man muss nicht nur seine eigene VPN-Infrastruktur aufbauen, sprich einen VPN-Server. Und das Telefon, egal wo es ist, macht als allererstes mal eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zu diesem VPN-Server auf. Und darüber schickt das alles. Das heißt, die Telefonate sind immer noch unverschlüsselt, aber ab da, wo der Server steht.
Richtig, das idealerweise VPN-Server und Callviver oder Asterisk, das geht in einem, wo man dann sagen kann, ok, das Paket fällt im Telefon noch in den Tunnel rein und erst wieder kurz vor der Software, die dann etwas anfängt, wieder raus. Immer end-to-end verschlüsselt.
Jetzt haben wir ja seit gestern Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also sie läuft noch nicht, aber beschlossen wurde sie, wo ja auch dann alle Kommunikationsdaten übermittelt werden sollen von den Providern.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie sie das machen bei direktem E-Nummer.
Wie meinst du das?
Wenn ich direkt ins Telefonnummer eingebe, wo es eine E-Nummer-Adresse ist, wo ich einen eigenen DNS habe, der irgendwie das mir auflöst, wo man auch nicht so wirklich mitloggen kann, wer da gerade welche Rufnummer anfragt, wie will man das loggen?
Na gut, die IP-Verbindungen sollen ja sozusagen jedes Paket mitgeloggt werden.
Ja, okay, da muss man vorher erstmal den Quanten-Speicher, einen optischen Speicher, whatever, also Speichermedien, die mehrere Terabit pro Stecklade kommen.
Weil ja eigentlich jedes einzelne Paket, UDP-Paket, einzeln quasi geloggt werden muss. Ja, sie werden da ein Speicherproblem haben, das stimmt schon, aber auch so generell das Vermitteln. Also in dem Moment, wo sozusagen die Vermittlung in den eigenen Server gelegt wird, ist man ja nicht mehr sehr von der Vermittlung von großen Telefonnetzen, die leicht abhörbar sind, abhängig. Das könnte natürlich auf jeden Fall schon mal eine neue Variante in dem Spiel sein.
Das war so der Knopf, den ich bei AS250 dann auch gesehen hab, dass das eine Chance ist für so Leute wie Yesman oder irgendwelche Aktivisten, denen das anzubieten. Hier Telefon, Datetelefon, sprich bei das OpenVPN, Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung, wozu? Ist kein kommerzieller Service. Das ist gerade, was Community angeht, wenn man sich da mit seiner Peer-Gruppe mal ein bisschen zusammen tut und sich so ein Asteriskinn stellt oder ein Coilweaver und eben seinen OpenVPN oder IPsec, was auch immer man da sprechen möchte.
Könnte ein Zukunftsmarkt werden. Jetzt haben wir schon viel über Protokolle und Software geredet. Mal jetzt in die Details der einzelnen Pakete einzugehen, das ist glaube ich ein bisschen over the top hier für den Podcast. Aber was man auf jeden Fall nochmal erwähnen sollte, weil das ja häufig auch bei solchen Voice over IP Seiten immer wieder genannt wird, neben dem SIP-Protokoll gibt es auch noch ein Protokoll namens EAX. Was hat es damit auf sich?
Das ist im Prinzip das Inter-Asterisk Exchange. Also das ist ein Protokoll, um was entwickelt wurde, um zwischen SIP-Switches Daten oder vor allem Bureau-Channels zu transportieren. Man musste ja unterscheiden zwischen den Signaling-Daten, die jetzt so ein paar SIP unterwegs sind, und den Bureau-Channels, die per RTP oder SRTP unterwegs sind.
Signaling ist das eigentliche Ich-will-an-rufen, das wir vorhin schon ausführlich beschrieben haben, und mit Bureau-Channels macht es jetzt die eigentlichen Daten.
Die Sprachdaten, genau.
Und bei SIP sind das immer für jeden Anruf ein einziger Verbindungsaufbau, und bei IAX wird das quasi zusammengefasst.
Na, bei SIP ist es so, dass du für einen Anruf auch einen Signaling-Kanal dazu hast, und bei IAX hast du einen Signaling-Kanal und dazu eine Handvoll Bureau-Channels, je nachdem, wie viele Daten da eben übertragen werden.
Das heißt, es ist dafür gedacht, dass man zwei Asteriskonstellationen hat, die untereinander sich verbinden, quasi so eine Querverschaltung.
Genau, und da ist auch schon was drin, was SIP eben fehlt und durchs Tunnen behäufen wird, da ist schon NUT-Unterstützung mit drin. Also das kann von sich aus NUT-Traverse...
Ah, das heißt, gibt es auch Telefone, die direkt IAX sprechen?
Es gibt auf jeden Fall Telefone, die auch direkt IAX sprechen. Ich müsste jetzt lügen, aber ich glaube, dass das NUM kann sogar. Also so richtig Hardphones, die man sich auf den Schreibtisch stellen kann.
Das heißt, wenn man tatsächlich Probleme hat, weil mit dem NUT, was man einsetzt, das irgendwie da nicht durchkommt, sollte man unter Umständen mehr Erfolg haben, wenn man sich mit IAX verbindet.
Genau, bei IAX ist das Problem, es ist halt kein ITF-Protokoll, kein Internet-Standard.
Das sind Providern nicht gemacht.
Ja, es gibt welche, die bieten das an, aber nicht viele. Aber es wird von Digium gepflegt. Und wenn Digium der Meinung ist, dass IAX ein neues Feature bekommen soll, was mit dem ITen inkompatibel ist, dann meinen die das halt und dann machen sie das. Dann ist sein Gerät eventuell update-fällig.
Jetzt reden wir immer über Telefone. Jetzt kann man natürlich auch mit seinem Rechner selber telefonieren. Viele Leute haben einfach so ein USB-Headset an ihrem Rechner dran und benutzen das heute schon für Audio-Chat und so. Da ist der Sprung zur Telefonie auch so groß nicht. Benutzt du ein Software-Phone? Also benutzt du eine Software als Telefon auch manchmal?
Gelegentlich zum Testen. Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich hab mich an diese Nokia E-Series-Geräte so gewöhnt. Man kann da irgendwie seinen Zip-Account eintragen und seine Access Points, wo man regelmäßig ist, und sagen, wenn du diesen Access Points siehst, dann registriere dich. Ich finde, diese Convenience, die so ein Telefon hat, ja, also ich hab gerne was in der Hand, so Hardware, wo man eine Nummer eingibt und sich ans Ohr hält.
Also trotzdem gibt es aber diese Programme.
Vorteil von Softphones vor allem ist, wenn man das mit Instamessaging kombiniert, wie es Skype schon vorgemacht hat. Ja, iChat, auch noch ein anderer Ansatz, das hatten wir vorhin.
Es gibt auch noch dieses Gizmo-Projekt, die selber einfach auch ein SIP-Anbieter sind und die aber so weit gehen, dass sie einem auch eine eigene Software anbieten, also ein eigenes Softphone anbieten. Die sind aber dann auch kompatibel. Und ja, das ist ein ganz schönes Tool, weil das alles irgendwie auf dem Mac läuft. Und sieht auch überall ordentlich aus. Und sie benutzen selber noch Java parallel. Also die haben eine sehr kluge Verquickung. Ich mag das ganz gerne. Ich benutze das jetzt auch nicht zu häufig, aber das hat, glaube ich, eher damit zu tun, dass ich mir noch nicht so richtig den Kopf gemacht habe, wie ich das alles integrieren will. Und weil ich da ganz mit dir konform bin, telefonieren, da will man irgendwie was in der Hand haben. Mir wäre eigentlich so ein USB-Telefonhörer noch am liebsten. Aber auch ein Headset kann manchmal helfen. Genau, ich stecke das irgendwie rein in meinen Computer. Dann weiß er schon, so ein Telefonhörer steckt drin. Jetzt möchte ich auch online sein. Und das dann eben so eine Software-Gleichverbindung macht. Das gibt es meines Wissens noch nicht. Ich verstehe immer nicht so richtig, warum. Aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass es einfach noch keiner mal so richtig zu Ende gedacht hat.
Der Bedarf ist vor allem noch nicht so groß, als dass die Leute wirklich das produktiv einsetzen. Meistens noch Spielerei.
Skype benutzen schon eine ganze Menge Leute.
Ja, aber da vor allem den Instant-Messenger. Was ich so gesehen habe an Leuten, die Skype benutzen, die sind vor allem von dieser Kombination. Man muss nicht unbedingt telefonieren, sondern kann erst mal per Instant-Message nachfragen. Ich glaube, das hat durchaus Potenzial, dass man da auch diese Presence hat, dass du eben siehst, der ist gerade da, aber der ist gerade beschäftigt, da schreiben wir ihm eine Nachricht.
Dass man gar nicht erst angerufen wird, das ja auch nervt.
Das, was man normal telefoniert, könnte man eigentlich auch via Instant-Message austauschen.
Von daher ist es noch eine große Frage, was sie letztlich durchsetzen wird. Es gibt da ja verschiedenste Ansätze. Die normalen ZIP-Telefone haben in der Regel keine Presence. Manche machen ihr eigenes Protokoll wie Skype, manche verquicken ZIP mit Chat, wie Apple das zum Beispiel bei iChat macht. Und dann gibt es auch noch den anderen Weg, den Google jetzt gerade verfolgt mit Google Talk. Was ja im Prinzip das andersrum macht. Sie insertieren ihr Audio-Protokoll in das Java-Protokoll. Das heißt, sie gehen eigentlich erstmal von Java aus. Bei Gizmo ist das eher so ein bisschen nebenbei. Also nach dem Motto, man kann telefonieren. Man hat dann außerdem auch noch einen Java-Server mit demselben Account. Das passt dann halt einfach wunderbar zusammen. Aber dieses Google-Talk, das Protokoll, was sie da vorgeschlagen haben, ist Jingle, was wohl auf allgemeine positive Resonanz gefunden hat. Das ist so Peer-to-Peer-Verbindungen von Java-Client, mit denen man dann eben auch Audio machen kann und dann wahrscheinlich über kurze Lange auch Video machen kann. Das wäre zumindest eine wirtschaftswerte Entwicklung. Ich sehe da an der Stelle auch das Rennen ehrlich gesagt noch ziemlich offen. Ich habe noch nicht so den Eindruck, dass sich irgendetwas wirklich so weit durchgesetzt hat, dass man sagen kann, das hat jetzt gewonnen. Skype hat zwar in so einem ersten Erfolg gelandet, aber es gab ja erst wieder Netzprobleme mit ihrem Peer-to-Peer-basierten Netzwerk.
Zurückzuführen, dass es kein offenes Protokoll ist, dass man denen vertrauen muss, dass sie das mit der Dynamik richtig hinbekommen. Und dass wenn eben so Events sind, wie mehrere User loggen sich gleichzeitig an, dass einem das nicht um die Ohren fliegt. Und das passiert.
Ja, da bin ich gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Was gibt es denn so für Ressourcen? Also wenn jetzt jemand das hier gehört hat und findet das Thema Voice over IP ganz interessant, weil wir jetzt die eine oder andere Anregung hier reingebracht haben, was uns glaube ich schon gelungen ist. Wo geht man dann hin? Gibt es auch so ein schönes Wiki, oder?
Ja, das Vibeinfo-Wiki, das ist im Prinzip so, die Anlaufstelle, egal ob man sich jetzt nur informieren möchte über ein bestimmtes Thema, oder ob man wirklich Konfigurationstipps oder eine Commandreference für seine Vibe-Software, die man da gerade hat.
Also Vibe, voipstrichinfo.org, das ist ein großes Wiki, steht eine Menge drin, also sowohl zur Software, viele Sachen, die wir jetzt hier erwähnt haben, sind da natürlich alle mit drin, aber auch zu Protokollen und How-To's.
Es gibt ganze Listen mit SIP-Anbietern in einzelnen Ländern, wenn man beispielsweise den Bedarf hat, ich brauche eine Rufnummer in Italien, weil ich habe da irgendwie eine Ferienwohnung, die ich halbjährlich vermiete, aber wenn ich in Deutschland bin, hätte ich gerne da so eine italienische Nummer, die da terminiert. In Deutschland kann man sich das da holen.
Stimmt, dann lockt man sich einfach da ein, dann hat man so eine italienische Nummer. Dann kann man so tun, als wäre man in Italien.
Da ist die Bundesnetzagentur auch ziemlich dahinter, dass die nomadische Nutzung, wie man das im Netzagentur facht, schon immer so sagt.
Oh Gott, die Globalisierung, so haben wir das nicht gemeint.
Ja, genau, dass man eben ruft, wenn man nur regional gebunden zuteilt. Also wenn ich jetzt eine 0-9-11-Nummer hab, dann STL Nürnberg. Und eine 0-3-0-Nummer hat in Berlin zu sein. Also man hat anhand der Nummer sehen zu können, wo diese Rufnummer terminiert. Also wenn ein SIP-Anbieter eine Rufnummer von Berlin, also aus dem 0-3-0-Bereich, einem User in Nürnberg zuteilen würde, dann würde er von der RECTP auf die Finger kriegen, beziehungsweise von der Bundesnetzagentur. Dafür gibt es die 0-3-2-Gasse. Das ist eine ortsungebundene Vorwahl für nomadische Nutzung. Da ist ja das Problem, dass sie das gehörig verkackt haben. Man hätte eigentlich bei so einer Rufnummer gerne, dass sie mit Ortsvorwahl wieder 0-9-11 oder 0-3-0 gleichgestellt ist. Auch tariflich. Das ist sie aber leider nicht. Die muss man anders terminieren. Gewöhnlich wird die Deutsche Telekom. Die Bepreisung dafür ist anders als für ein Festnetzgespräch. Was dann dazu führt, dass es keiner nutzt. Die Akzeptanz ist einfach mal nicht da. Ich habe auch noch keinen anderen außer der Deutsche Telekom gesehen, die einem 0-3-2-Nummern anbieten.
Warum mehr zahlen? Das macht ja alles irgendwie keinen Sinn. Das heißt, die normalische Nutzung wird aber trotzdem gemacht, egal wie die sich da bemühen, dass man nachweise liefert. Da wird dann noch mal eine Briefkastenfirma angemietet und fertig ist die Laube. Ja, das ist albern. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sich das noch lange durchsetzen wird mit den regionalen Vorwahlen, weil es ja auch jetzt mit Weiterleitung, Nummernübernahme usw. eh alles schon komplett durcheinander ist. Ja, gut, ich denke, haben wir es, oder? Mir fällt jetzt nichts mehr ein. Gut, das war es. Chaosradio Express, Nummer 52, der am Tage 1 nach der Beschließung der Vorarztdatenspeicherung, das ist der 10. November 2007. Ich habe ja gesagt, dass ich das Datum ansagen will. Das habe ich am Anfang schon wieder vergessen. Mal gucken, ob das noch was wird. Vielen Dank, Nibbler.
Wir haben gesehen, dass trotz dieser Vorarztdatenspeicherung der Horizont sich öffnet für Möglichkeiten.
Es ist Zeit für kreative Lösungen. Ein paar Ansätze, wie man diese kreativen Lösungen, zumindest was die Telefoniererei betrifft, wie man die verfolgen kann, haben wir hoffentlich gegeben. Also Leute an die Terminals. Konfiguriert mal was Schönes. Ich würde es gerne sehen, wenn es mal leicht zu bedienende Systeme gibt, die man sich schnell zu Hause gut installieren kann. Da ist glaube ich noch eine Menge für typische Anwendungsszenarios noch eine Menge zu machen. Andererseits natürlich solche Community-Projekte, so wie du das mit deinem AS250 gemacht hast, insbesondere so auf Telefonie, wo einfach mal für Organisationen eine schnelle Lösung gegeben wird, dass man sich da leicht vernetzen kann, billig telefonieren kann, indem man Internet benutzt, mobiles und auch noch halbwegs vielleicht auch noch das an Verschlüsselung ausnutzt und an Datenvermeidung insbesondere was Logs betrifft. Was da noch zu holen ist. Auf jeden Fall gibt es noch Nachholbedarf im Verschlüsselungsbereich, das ist ganz offensichtlich. Aber bin mir sicher, das ist alles nur eine Frage der Zeit. Denn mit steigender Überwachung steigt der Druck und da wird es sicherlich nicht mehr lange dauern. Insofern bedanken wir uns bei den Politikern für die übermäßige Überwachung. Sie bringt uns dann endlich ordentlich Verschlüsselungssysteme. In diesem Sinne sagen wir mal Tschüss. Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.